the statement read the Duke of Sussex
will attend the coronation service at
Westminster Abbey on May 6. the Duchess
of Sussex will remain in California with
Prince Archie and Princess lilibit a
compromise it seems for the new king
Prince Harry hasn't been in the UK much
since he and Megan step back as working
Royals in 2020. he attended Prince
Phillips's funeral and the couple
returned when Queen Elizabeth died
Prince Harry was also here last month to
attend a high court hearing in his case
against the Publishers of a British
tabloid newspaper but while promoting
his best-selling bombshell Memoir spare
he told 60 Minutes as Anderson Cooper in
January he wanted to sit down with
members of his family to discuss the
issues he's been so open about privately